il y en a une qui a menti et je me suis
rendu compte
moi capucine à la monty non non regardez
les images
chacun voit là va boire un verre tous
ensemble chacun va se coucher et puis
bonne quarantaine de minutes après je
suis en pyjama et tout je suis sous la
couette et j'entends même pas quelqu'un
toqués j'entends quelqu'un gratter et
j'ai ouvert la porte et j'ai vu notre
notre canapé lui qui m'a dit voilà qui
m'attend rien à ma proposition est alors
de câlins d'alors
alors j'ai refusé mais c'est à bluff
capucine nous avait dit qu'elle avait
été grattée à la porte dès lors à non ça
c'est call you know là pour qu'elle lui
fasse un câlin et et bien j'ai piqué les
captures de monique lemoine mais moi
j'étais au courant de la supercherie et
oui regardez la vérité
d'un convoi des braves
non
sauf que
oui ah oui mais oui et oui et oui vous
aviez menti
capucine ici sachez le cantilien
mensonge oui on le sait toujours que
jamais mentir dans cette émission non
séparés ferme de faire un bon on n'est
pas chez votre mère non mais je vous le
dis et capucine prouve démenti alors non
je n'ai pas menti vraiment lé graffin
non oui et je n'ai pas demandé à quelle
heure on sent vraiment aller dans sa
chambre après c'est vrai que je vais pas
demander à un câlin mais c'était plus
justement pour lui faire une petite
avance que j'ai menti pour lui faire
comprendre la vérité ce qui s'est passé
c'est que il n'aura par là dessus edit à
capucine je vais dire un truc et t'en
fais pas assez bizarre mais t'en fais
pas et après la résolution c'était après
la pub et à la pub capucines à 10 et
n'aura non mais dis que c'est vrai non
non et non il est pas bien mais pas
bluff et parce qu'il trouvait que
c'était bien ça les faire parler allez
bon bah merci voilà alors ça
mais est-ce qu'ils ont une sanction la
sanction elle a déjà tous les jours